you are you are a native of Bavaria
hello yeah okay yeah did you so
obviously but you're living here in this
country you did celebrate the 4th of
July did you do anything to celebrate no
I was here for this time of independent
for you yeah but it's too loud for me so
I was putting things in ear holes yes to
celebrate your birthday I was reaching a
Theotokos effect biographies oh yeah oh
that's good so you learned a lot about
our country yeah he was I think he
carries a small branch and is tiptoeing
around yes no no walk quietly carry a
big stick yes yes no not really
now there so you don't do enjoy our 4th
of July don't like the fireworks well
well I like firework is much better
I've heard they're called a firecracker
as well yeah it's firecracker very
racist so I would say maybe prefer I
don't know a fire honky oh yeah I see
what you're saying fire Caucasian ok
soon ok so are there any are there any
German holidays that you guys have that
we don't have yeah we have national
sandwiched a German sandwich day wait
well why do you celebrate the sandwich a
sandwich for us is a new item we are we
do not we did not know to like take one
and one and smacky eat it yeah yeah we
will just take one slap a slapping man
[ __ ] yeah
so the idea of putting two pieces of
bread what yeah exactly who it's that
one okay thing know Wikipedia okay